[Música]
bienvenidos de nuevo a directo con 26
este es el programa especial de france
24 para debatir lo que ocurre en la
cumbre climática de la onu en glasgow
draco 26 allí está nuestra enviada
especial marina a colorado con todas las
actualizaciones de los debates que están
en proceso marín a bienvenida de nuevo y
hoy la jornada se centró en el activismo
juvenil cuéntenos qué fue lo que pasó
bueno pues las calles de glasgow se
llenaron con miles de personas tanto
pequeñas tanto tan pequeñas como de los
dos desde los dos años hasta adultos
mayores para pedir justicia climática
justicia social y que los gobiernos y
los líderes que están aquí reunidos
pongan planes detallados de cómo van a
convertir en acción las palabras y lo
que están prometiendo durante las
negociaciones de catumbela la líder
activista ambiental sueca lideró las
marchas y dieron algunos discursos
después en la plaza de la alcaldía de
glasgow donde ella dijo que la cob 26
iba a ser un fracaso si los políticos no
se ponían a trabajar en acciones
precisas y más concretas también hubo
otros muchísimos otros eventos
obviamente aquí dentro del recinto de la
copa también y era a unos metros de aquí
de donde están las instalaciones donde
estamos ahora hubo una instalación en la
que trajeron un bloque un icebergs de
cuatro toneladas desde en la cndh ya
para recordarnos que el ártico se está
derritiendo o se está calentando más
bien al doble de la velocidad que lo
está haciendo el resto del planeta y
para llamar la atención acerca de los
peligros que el derretimiento de las
capas de hielo producirían porque dentro
de esas capas hay muchísimos gases de
efecto invernadero atrapados pero
también el día estuvo dedicado a la
educación y ha habido muchísimos eventos
y entre ellos anuncios de 23 países que
van a incluir la educación climática en
el centro de sus programas educacionales
bueno y increíble lo que nos está
contando pero volvamos al primer tema
del que usted habló los jóvenes usted
está con gaby va es de yuberney ser de
américa latina que nos cuentan ustedes
desde glasgow
claro que sí pues me acompaña viva ese
como bien lo comentaba es quien se
encarga de dirigir ferney tours en
latinoamérica latinoamérica y el caribe
muchas gracias por estar en france 24
usted lleva muchos años en el activismo
ambiental que fue lo que lo que le
inspiró a la realidad toda mi vida yo
crecí en una casa que mis padres ya
estaban involucrados con eso por eso fue
algo muy natural porque toda mi vida
sigue involucrado en mi ciudad sino la
acción es cuando estaba más viejo vi la
oportunidad de
estar junto de un grupo de jóvenes y
empiece a hacer eso también a solo a
como
independientemente y vi que era lo que
quería continuar haciendo continuar
haciendo acciones llamando por justicia
climática en latinoamérica imbécil y
cuál es la importancia de que
latinoamérica está representada aquí en
el 26 y en las afueras creo que
latinoamérica tenemos muchas
posibilidades de las soluciones
a la crisis la crisis climática que
vivimos porque tenemos mucha experiencia
defendiendo la naturaleza por todas las
partes creo que tenemos muchos indígenas
de grupos varones y quilombolas que ya
están haciendo acciones en los
territorios y creo que en latinoamérica
tenemos mucho la oportunidad de enseñar
todo el mundo y creo que cuando tenemos
el surdo global acá en popa tenemos una
visión diferente y otras propuestas que
creo que son muy importantes de ser y de
estar en las decisiones de estar al
frente de las decisiones que están
haciendo siendo dichas acá tú tienes una
licenciatura en relaciones
internacionales y en manejo de políticas
públicas que tan frustrante es ver lo
que está pasando aquí con los políticos
que no toman acciones es muy frustrante
la situación que vemos acá porque
estamos en la cop 26 y hace como al
menos 27 años con la pandemia qué
hay todos los años una reunión de todos
los líderes que ya saben que está
pasando por eso creo que
veo ahora que tenemos mucho que hacer
para llamar la atención para que alguien
acciones ahora
y para que todas las personas sean
incluidas de las decisiones por eso creo
que cuando que los líderes tienen que
ver que las soluciones de ahí están y
que si empiezan a ver localmente en cada
ciudad y cada territorio lo que ya has
hicimos hay una oportunidad de tener las
soluciones que queremos pero si no
empiezan a incluir todas las personas en
las tomas de decisiones detener a
nosotros los jóvenes
de toda latinoamérica haciendo eso no
cambiaremos la situación que vivimos la
bbc muchísimas gracias por su tiempo en
france 24 y con este llamado a la
inclusión social a la inclusión
climática nos despedimos desde glasgow
gracias a ustedes por toda la
información y como decía marina con este
llamado a la justicia climática
terminamos por ahora pero sigan
conectados a la señal de france 24
[Música]